Oh welcome to the newest Cora v-log this
is probably gonna be a really short one
because not a whole ton happen in this
one uh nothing was best stuff happened
it's just very quick to explain yeah
pretty much the MCOs prince Emperor
whatever he got kidnapped core can now
see through vines that's pretty court
just the ground that that's pretty neat
and they're pretty much gonna chat down
that learned it from Toph when did you
meet tough this is oh yeah I forgot to
mention it is reunited with everybody
you know they're the family everybody uh
and yeah it looks like they're gonna
chop down the for lack of better term
the Avatar Tree of Life it's gotten very
literally avatar yeah I know I'm just
like damn it I don't want to reference
that movie but yeah pretty much they're
gonna chop that down and I just don't
see a bail between Toph Lyla Garrity's
be like yeah yeah yeah whatever it just
like puts up a big wall and like
destroys him or something got the
spirit tree so that's kind of
the gist of it I mean anything I love to
anything else out no I mean it's a good
episode it's just it's kind of a
breather episode the point when the plot
is this densely packed any episode
that's not really just
plop-plop-plop-plop lot is gonna always
seem lesser just by comparison so it's
it's not a bad episode it's just this is
very much about getting characters from
point A to point B or just taking a
breath so there's just not a ton to talk
about it's just moving a couple of chess
pieces into place it's like okay well
you needed the Prince to get abducted so
they'll go chase after him and then
bolin and varrick meet up with some
refugees and help them out and yeah
that's pretty much it the not a lot of
complaints is a couple of small things
I'd the fight between Asami and Korra
there seemed a touch out of came out of
nowhere I don't mind if they have a
fight and I don't mind if Asami seems
upset about so it just with there was no
segue until
nowhere and resolve this is like really
quickly to see my father what do you
think that's a good idea
how dare you things out a good idea I'm
done and I'm like well where did this
come from like it I get that you know
they may want to address that it's just
it's almost like the plot is so densely
packed that they had to just have no way
to segue into this fight so it just
bursts out of nowhere at the dinner
table there and I'm like okay I guess
they're upset at each other and then
that seemed resolved quick so yeah that
came out of nowhere and I think the only
other thing is I feel bad for macho cuz
he got stuck with this guy but at the
same time I really do his job yeah yeah
the second he's is like I'm hitting the
restroom come follow me he's like no and
I was just like well I wonder what's
gonna happen yeah I think it's like
that's not a good bodyguard no matter
how insufferable the door you know I
mean this guy is doesn't people after
him it's kind of legit reason for people
to go after yeah he was right outside
the door at least maybe you could hear
him go like but I the big thing for me I
really like I felt it's just really cool
an avatar that can like just put her
hand to the ground and could just sense
everything and sense where everybody
yeah I was just like that's really cool
like and it makes sense you know being
mm sounds a really cool gonna give
tension give Korra a chance to be useful
after getting her ass handed to her yeah
that's why I like just a like and this
is something only she not only can she
do but it's not something that she was
just kind of born with or you know like
or even the other avatars were taught is
just passed on her and this was
something that's like it's it seems like
some it's really hard to pick up you
know talking to it cuz she's blind you
know but it's one of those things where
it's like yeah you put your hand out you
just sense where the person is like
that's impressive you know it's a really
cool thing and it's like oh maybe that
can be passed on to the next avatar it's
a bellick valley that's a cool thing too
I'm sure
come back if that trees attack maybe
Cora will sensitive yeah that'd be
interesting actually how they get cut
down that giant chainsaws really really
really changes yes but then Chuck Norris
would come in step it with his hand you
know even if it's huge he'll still just
stop it those little hand so yeah I
think the only other thing which I
thought was cool was Bolin having a lot
of redemption for Bolin I feel like he's
finally come into his own like you know
he admits straight up it's like alright
we both got tricked by this person like
now it's time for us to step up and when
he needs to
he really does because the last time
they got screwed because Varrick got
caught but this time Bolin like
unleashes the lava and goes to town and
then Varrick pitches in by shutting the
mecca's off somebody point out my public
face when it was like no love for
varicose yes he shut the mecca's down
that's awesome no love America love once
there's like how dare you but so yeah
that was really cool and apart from that
not much else to do this is like this is
just sort of like a transition episode
to get a couple of other plot points
rolling so which is fine I'm not
complaining about that it's just as they
say when the plots this densely packed I
don't know what else when you get an
episode like this it's very little to
talk about so I'll say the only other
thing I was thinking about you coming
over while I was trying to cuz we both
saw this I think a day or two ago and I
was driving always think in my head like
you know yeah now what wait did that
happen the Caesars at the last season
and I think it's been a really long time
since I remember an avatar show where I
was saying was that this season or last
season because they actually did seem to
flow together pretty well and they
seemed very much in the same universe
where I say well one was sort of season
one with sort of its own thing season
two it sort of its own thing you know in
some ways a repeat season why this one
it's like yeah they even though they had
different villains they both kind of
came to a close there is the sense that
they do connect
more and it could because they're
playing them like right after each other
I mean season four we just launched
right into that after three um but yeah
I do kind of like that it's really four
I kind of remember you know or seemed
connect because there's way more of
addressing of the consequences from
season three we didn't get that as much
with season two it's like it's about
spirits it's about change and then I
don't feel like they ever went very far
with I feel like there's more dealt with
that now with using the spirit vines and
Asami rebuilding the whole city with the
roads I love that it's like take this
road no take this one I rebuilt this so
yeah no it was still good I mean there's
nothing wrong with it I think it like
you say it's just the breather episode
just wanted to like you know catch your
breath and go okay you know just uh
whoo now back to the actually I'm back
to the big stuff so yeah that's about it
we'll see it the next one
take care